so welcome to the October PI data and
Arbor I just wanted to take a second to
thank our sponsors and I'm focused for
the meetup TD Ameritrade so this
beautiful space and - forth and if you
have any feedback there is our Twitter
navel and our email address or you can
talk to one of the organizers if there's
anything you wanted to bring up about
today some important points - emergency
exits oh there's an emergency exit over
here and then also back the way it came
like I said any feedback to email us and
also we're in a borrowed space please
make sure to clean up after yourself
so for Q&A at the end unless quick hold
questions until the end please phrase
your question in the form of a question
try to keep questions to 30 seconds or
less
avoid long statements or monologues and
there will be time for open discussions
after Q&A so now I'm going to read the
PI data code of conduct pi data is
dedicated to providing a harassment free
meeting experience for everyone
regardless of gender sexual orientation
gender identity and expression
disability physical appearance body size
race religion or experience we do not
tolerate harassment of meeting
participants in any form
all communication should be appropriate
for professional audience including
people of many different backgrounds and
levels of experience sexual language and
imagery is not appropriate for any of
our meetup events be kind to others do
not insult or put-down other attendees
behave professionally remember that
harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for high data attendees violating these
rules may be asked to leave at the
meetup at the sole discretion of the
meetup organizers thank you for making
this for helping make this a welcoming
friendly event for all so now we're
gonna do a quick icebreaker so turn to
someone you don't know introduce
yourself and our icebreaker for my
lovely speaker is what is your favorite
fall activity um so a couple
announcements for this month in data
science so the midis symposium is
November 13th to 15th and you can take a
look at their website for more
information about that there's also a PI
data Los Angeles in December which will
be at Cal State Los Angeles and you can
take a look at their website as well and
then on November 2nd there is a Bay Area
woman in machine learning and data
science sponsored sprint sorry I was
like I'm missing a word a sprint which
is actually a group that's led by our
speaker next month so they're having
that in November and you can take a look
and our our next event will be ratio
shake on community building the good and
bad and that will be Wednesday November
13th
so now we have an opportunity for anyone
out in the community who has you know an
announcement of any sort so a job you're
looking for a job you're hiring for any
other sort of announcement
my name's Matt I work for XP logistics
we're trucking company so we around the
country we're hiring for a data
scientist we have really interesting
data problems it wouldn't sound like it
because we're a trucking company but we
do network optimization we enter your
statistical analysis we do freight flow
optimization it's incredibly deep skills
we're looking for are you know one two
three years of Python when the 30 years
of Java or the three years of sequel any
of those who make you stand out but
basically the ability to verbalize a
data problem and turn it into software
supposed to be kind of software based
data science eliminating time skillset
great thanks so much right we're still
hiring on our team for AI engineer if
you have experience in
birthday party it's a little bit more a
senior
please come
it's through interactions it's on Rai
research of the design team and then
also I run
we have a meet-up this October 24th it's
a Thursday in spark if you're interested
in that it's on meetup complex oh great
I'm that I'm a fossil 51 we're kind of a
small start-up doing the video so we're
looking for we were looking at software
position software engineering position
don't think we have some data science
missions open as well come talk to me or
just an enter website box if you want to
crawl under careers if you're interested
there's way there talk to me after if
you're interested thanks
my name is Marcel I am looking for a job
so I I might my background is in
software engineering and my PhD is in
traditional biology so my less work was
as a design consultant here
work with clients in traditional
statistical analysis neurosis evolution
and the florist but you can choose
so I had to keep my last shot for taking
care of my two kids who I'm dead but I'm
looking to re-enter so I'm going to do
precise positions including our city's
close network button
great thank you
any other announcements
great
but well now I'm going to introduce our
speaker timing verdict a [ __ ] is the
data scientist at devoted health a new
health care company offering Medicare
Advantage plans where she focuses on
marketing and sales analytics she
previously worked on a team at IBM
Watson health to develop an application
for primary care providers she lives in
Boston and likes to read and hike in her
spare time
welcome Tanya so the title of my talk is
pipelines that bend but don't break that
is focused on designing and refactoring
pipeline logic over the course of its
its time when we transform data in a
repeatable fashion so I'll go more into
depth on that but first a little bit
more about me so it's my LinkedIn
profile picture I am a data scientist at
devoted health as was mentioned before
that I was a data scientist on gemstone
which is a Watson for patient care
insights IBM Watson health we worked on
a similarity machine learning algorithm
that helped pick similar patients to the
one the doctor was working with and say
what they did well on and then before
that I worked in health services
research at Boston Children's Hospital
mapping the US healthcare system and
consolidation across the u.s. for a
research project so a little bit about
devoted there are a lot of pictures here
so devoted health is since my examples
coming from devoted this is important
devoted health is a Medicare Advantage
company where fairly young we've been
taking care of members since January and
I'll explain more about what medicare
advantages we're based in Boston
actually and watham a little bit to the
west and right now we take care of
members in Florida and this is a picture
of our offices from from a venture fizz
article and a picture of our website
which you can access so I didn't have
this slide in here but I was talking to
Sean he's from Canada and I was like I
should probably give like a quick
background on Medicare some Medicare is
the US federal hell
insurance program for people over 65 you
pay in your whole life or your working
life and it also covers younger people
with disabilities and people with
end-stage renal disease medicare has
several parts part a is their Hospital
coverage you know me go to the ER and
you're seen at the hospital you're in
Part B is your senior primary care
physician or any other specialist Part D
is prescription drug coverage and the
Medicare Advantage is some kind of
called Part C which is a little bit
confusing but it covers Part A and B
sometimes Part D and then additional
benefits and it's the same government
benefits but administered by a private
company so a Medicare Advantage company
will administer the Medicare benefits
and do all the claim handling and so on
that CMS would usually do so some
important things about devoted founding
principle kind of things we put members
first and this affects not only customer
care but also the way we think about
analytics and our analytics priorities
we're also very data-centric and
technology centric we've had data
scientists on the team from the
beginning our head of technology is DJ
Patel who is a data scientist under
Obama and we have a pretty robust data
team for a company our age and in this
space and technology centric we also
have a very big engineering team and we
build out a lot of systems ourselves as
opposed to contracting with a lot of
vendors and then we're very young like I
mentioned we're about 2 years old and
we've been serving members since January
so this is actually we're going into our
second year as a Medicare company just
super exciting time data changes really
quickly we might see something we need
that we didn't realize we needed from
this year to last year part of that is
we actually just expanded to another
state so all the data problems that come
with that moving from we were just in
Florida and now we're in Florida and
Texas so now we have Central Time
and many other data things that needed
to change so some examples of systems
that devoted that we get data from what
so our engineering team built a medical
claims processing system we have member
application processing and a full
customer relationship management system
so who are prospective members and how
have they interacted with us we also
have some integrations with vendors we
get call data from an external vendor
and then we have our Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid Services so this
the government arm CMS communications
are handled through a vendor and then
from from my perspective TV marketing
management is also handled handled with
a with a vendor so we send them how well
or how many calls were getting from
different campaigns and they decide when
to run different slots so the data team
had to voted and some of the tools we
use I heard last month you also had some
airflow in the presentation so I'm going
to talk about air flow a little bit
again but it's a really important tool
here so we do a lot of things one of the
things we do is we write the analytics
pipelines that power the analytics the
dashboards and so on our data warehouse
is snowflake and which has its own
sequel dialect and we also use Python to
do those transformations so just a quick
background on airflow air flow runs
directed acyclic graphs these DAGs which
basically tell you when different parts
of the transformation run and how they
depend on each other so here's an
example of a dag my example marketing
dag and from this example you can see
campaign level look up these are all
sequel scripts in this example but they
could also be Python operators we have a
mix and most of the pipelines so
campaign level lookup would run
first and create a campaign level table
then calls and lead forums depend on
campaign level look up and then
responses would call them the calls and
lead form submissions and these are all
laid out in some kind of usually Python
but we also have a ya mole template that
we sit on top of it to put out what
dependencies are there and how things
move from one to the other so and then
we build these pipelines and then we can
build dashboards on top of them and we
use periscope it's very similar to
looker or tableau where you have a
sequel layer to extract and transform
the data and then some kind of UI to
create a graph and there we use
snowflake sequel to hit the warehouse
and this dashboard is an example from
the periscope website but ours look
pretty similar and then we also do some
integrations with our engineering
application layer which is written and
go typically these are queries to the
warehouse that need to go to an external
place like a provider group or or a
vendor but these can also be at some
point data products feeding back into
the go layer so here's an example of the
way our analytics pipelines work at
devoted a diagram so we have source data
and source data can come from a few
different places but mainly it comes
from our go application layer so this is
the claims processing and the
application management that I mentioned
earlier we make a copy of the source
data into snowflake with ETL processes
and then there's a set of analytics
pipelines that are run on air flow tags
that create analytics tables and then
the goal is to build most of our
analyses which typically periscope layer
off of those analytics tables
an example of an analytics table this is
one that is quite popular and drives a
lot of reports is a member month table
so in this example we have just one
member number one and two months where
they were active January and February
and we also see they switched Pete
primary care providers PCP
so in January they were with Mary
Shelley and then in March or February
they were with Marc Brown so you can see
there's a lot of things that a lot of
questions you can get off of this table
much more easily than off of a source
table that had one row per member things
like how many members did we have with
Mary Shelley in February is a very
specific question but also how many
active members did we have in each month
is a question that you really want to
know to see over time so that's this
chart at the bottom is kind of a mock of
what that might look like what do I do
it devoted so I am on the sales and
marketing team and I build marketing and
sales pipelines and dashboards mainly to
see how well different campaigns are
doing and with what people so how well
different campaigns how well different
agents just metrics around sales
performance and it's an example this is
actually a chart I built
I built the member him on the table at
the very beginning so and this talk in
particular is going to focus on this
analytic pipeline arrow so the ones that
were running in DAGs basically we have a
I'm going to talk about a table that we
had that was at the prospect level and
tracked all of the significant
milestones in a prospects sales timeline
and how we ended up changing that
refactoring that code to work better
over time and what things we thought
about during that and what things we
think about going forward in situations
like this and the reason I thought to do
this talk
oh well so this is our particular use
case with analytics pipelines but I also
think this kind of design and
refactoring framework is relevant if
you're just working from source data or
a copy of the source data to an analysis
or even if you're building features in a
repeatable way where you might want to
add features in the future or run the
same model in a week on new data this
kind of repeatable transformation is
leads to code issues that you need to
think about and resolve kind of
constantly so while I was preparing for
this talk I came across a guide by dr.
Ernst at University of Washington on
giving technical presentations and he
was more talking about for research
purposes but I also thought it was quite
relevant he said there were three things
you need to convince an audience of in
order to have a good presentation the
first is that it's worthwhile second is
that it's hard and third is that it's
solved so I'm going to try and convince
you these things over the course of the
presentation but I also wanted to get a
leg up and just say right off why I
think these things are true at the
beginning so this is worthwhile cleaning
updated by plans thinking about design
from the beginning modularizing and then
refactoring in order to make things
clean is worthwhile because it saves a
lot of time a lot of debugging a lot of
testing time we ended up saving quite a
lot of time it also makes the code a lot
cleaner for what if you want it on board
someone new to the project who doesn't
have the history that you do it's hard
because we want to build to a particular
use case at the beginning and I'm sure
everyone's had an experience where
you're building a model and you have a
set of features at the beginning that
you want to use so you create the sequel
or the Python to create those features
and then later when you're adding a new
feature it doesn't quite fit into the
scripts that you made to start there's a
lot of there's a lot of pressure and
that creates this tendency
to go straight towards the problem that
you are working at from the beginning
without thinking about where it might be
in the future and then it's solved I
would say this is a good framework to
think about it so it solved in the sense
that this framework has helped us a lot
I would not say that our pipelines are
perfect or thinking about this makes
perfect pipelines but I think it's kind
of an ongoing process and learning
process that I've had over the course of
my career so far so the beginning is a
prospect funnel so this is the example
I'm going to go through with the
prospect level table let me start by
explaining what happens operationally in
marketing at devoted here's an example
of a campaign that we ran last year on
YouTube the important thing about this
campaign from an operational perspective
so a prospect is watching YouTube and
sees this campaign come up and decides
that this is something they're
interested in so they give this number a
call at the bottom this number routes to
our telesales line so then they talk
with an agent the agent convinces them
that it's a good idea to set up an
appointment checks that they're
qualified and so on and they set up an
appointment with a field sales agent
it's kind of complicated just because
the nature of Medicare is just a it's a
it's a it's less of a consumer product
and more of a decision you make for your
life so people want to talk to people on
the phone and then in person so you
might set up an appointment with a field
sales agent you go meet with them at a
provider office or at your home or at a
Duncan there's all kinds of things that
happen in sales and you talk with the
field sales agent and decide that
devoted is right for you and then you
apply so that's what happens
operationally on the data side yes
yeah so that is a complicated data
problem because we can't get the
demographics until we talk to the person
right so we do have demographics for the
people we talked to who are willing to
tell us how old they are and so on but
we do have a set of calls that we'll
never know if it was a qualified person
who called but there are so we do have
some digital channels and there are
people who are qualified who are on the
channels but I will say direct mail is
probably our biggest in the industry in
general it's pretty well known that
direct mail is the way to reach people
who are over 65 usually but that doesn't
mean diversifying is bad yeah totally
so yeah it's sort of follow up on that
it could totally happen that somebody
calls in to this number and says hey my
dad is interested and then leaves a
callback number for their dad I think
the more likely situation is they would
send their parent the number to talk to
us but we do sometimes talk to to the
children if they are in the telesales
process they don't have to be appointed
to talk to us but but when their members
that we do need like a an official
appointee in order to talk about medical
information with a child does that
answer okay any other questions okay
so from a data perspective there's
something like 10 to 20 tables that go
into this but here's a couple of
examples so one we might have and we do
have a table that stores marketing
number to campaign so when somebody
calls in from a certain marketing number
I can say okay that's campaign FL 180
the state is Florida here's the channel
and some other metadata about it this is
an English ad so that's kind of a lookup
table and then we also have data on who
called in when so here we can see
somebody called this marketing number at
this time and that's how we can kind of
link who called different campaigns and
as you can see to your point
sometimes our prospect ideas know so if
we don't get data from them we just know
a call came in to that channel but we
can't link who it was or whether they
were qualified so with all of this data
we thought about the kind of units that
we wanted to track and what we came up
with was a prospect level table what
campaign they responded in to who they
talked to and then kind of the outcomes
so was there an appointment and was
there an application and this is how we
envisioned it when we moon we set out
and at the beginning we started off
making this a little over a year ago
before we were using air flow our
warehouse was redshift and a lot of us
actually happened in the periscope layer
so one thing that happened so in the
periscope layer you can create views so
views are kind of just in case to make
sure everyone's on the same playing
field views are like temporary tables
that only exist in your session and you
can create those in periscope so we had
a set of periscope views that did this
matching logic it's not super
sustainable and which is one of the
reasons we decided to move it into
pipelines on air flow once we got air
flow
in the middle we were actually running
cron jobs sequel scripts on on in in
bash saying like when each one would run
and which would run after the others
airflow definitely improved that so some
decisions from the start the situation I
outlined was kind of the most
straightforward thing that happens data
is never super straightforward so what
happens if somebody calls in for
multiple campaigns or multiple times to
the same campaign before they apply and
this is campaign attribution it's a
really common marketing problem so here
say somebody called into that YouTube ad
in August and then decided they didn't
want to make an appointment and then a
month later they called in for a
different YouTube ad and then they
decided to apply and go through the
whole process
do we give credit to the first campaigns
because that's what presumably how they
heard about us the first time or do we
give credit to the campaign that brought
them in or do we do some kind of
weighting system and a lot of companies
do this differently there are like
parabolic methods where you weight the
first and last and less in the middle
but this was a decision that we came up
against very quickly associated one
called number how do you tag them up to
different campaign
yeah so campaigns can run concurrently
in fact we're usually running at least a
dozen campaigns in like different
mediums but each one has a different
number so this we use is a lookup so if
somebody calls into this number we know
it goes to this campaign we try not or
we don't use over numbers at the same
time overlapping but we do reuse numbers
so we usually have a time period on this
table as well but that's really
important so does that answer okay cool
so that question what happens if
somebody calls them for multiple
campaigns you would think it wouldn't
come up a lot it totally comes up a lot
we have some people with twenty
responses some of them to the same
campaign like somebody sees a YouTube ad
and calls in five times in the same ad
it's hard to predict a clean way that
people will behave in data and then what
happens oh and so I should say what we
did with this at the beginning so we
were creating a prospect level table we
decided to use first campaign to start
out so the first campaign that touches a
prospect we would say that's how they
heard about us we're gonna give the
application to that campaign and I'll
show what that looks like in a second
and then what happens if someone has
more than one appointment or more than
one application that's another thing
you're like okay so once they make the
purchase or so on there that is a cycle
and we want a different cycle but we
have a bunch of people who might sign up
for an appointment decide they don't
want to apply then and then like a month
later they decide to meet with the sales
agent again do another appointment which
would we store in the table and this is
important for metrics like time from
their response to the appointment things
that we might want to track if so we
also decided to do first appointment and
first application the first application
if your applications denied you might
apply again if you apply with us become
a member it disenroll decide to apply
again that's another thing that can
happen so here's what prospect funnel
started looking like
so a row for each prospect the first
campaign that brought them in the first
appointment and the first application so
you can see there's some limits to this
right there's a lot of data that's
missing from this table that were kind
of cutting out along the way but it
worked for us for a while especially for
our first Medicare is very cyclic so
Medicare Advantage so you can apply in
the fall in fact we just opened up
yesterday so most people can apply only
in the fall so we had our first sales
cycle a lot of this worked for being a
lot of prospects first contact with us
which made sense and then it grew so
code gross I'm sure anyone who's had to
either maintain someone else's code or
work with the same piece of code over a
period of years in in our pipelines how
it ended up growing was we would get
further questions so things like the
time between the response and the
appointment or incorporating a piece of
data about a prospect and it grew to be
a little bit untenable as a pipeline
script we ended up with I mean here I'm
showing four columns there were actually
about 70 by the time we decided to
retract our sequel ended up being about
seven hundred lines of sequel and we
used a lot of common table expressions
so CT es which are kind of like sub
queries in that they create a table that
only exists for the query so we had
about 30 of those in order to construct
that end 77 D column table so here's a
more general list about signs it was
time to refer which I think are relevant
whether you're doing pipelines or
transforming data in some other way
these are just some things that we
started noticing so we started to get a
lot of need for inner
mediate data remember we're starting
here but look up and then the calls and
going straight to this without exposing
any tables in between so some of the
questions we started getting which made
a lot of sense and we ended up changing
to adjust for these but how many calls
did we get from campaign 370 so from
this table I could tell you at least two
potentially infinite right so maybe
prospect one the first campaign they
called in to is 370 and then they called
in to 370 20 more times so technically
we got 22 calls for campaign 370 but
only two prospects and that's data that
we've lost moving from the source data
to here another example is if I wanted
to know how many people call into
campaign 380 so on this table the answer
is none but maybe prospect to called
into 370 first and then called into 380
a month later and that applied so in
this table we can't tell that at all and
380 looks like it didn't do anything so
explaining and documenting the code grew
harder this is something that can happen
no matter how well you refactor how you
think about setting things up but we
have a particularly hard time because of
all the CTS so if you're a new developer
coming on to this pipeline and you want
to make a change so my example change
here is I want to add the prospectus if
code at the time of the call so I can
know whether they were eligible so
ideally I would add this the here's an
example of two CTS one is a call CTE and
the other one is a prospect CTE
so ideally I would add zip code for the
prospect to the call level CT because
technically of a prospect called in
multiple times and gave us different zip
codes it could change over time but zip
code is stored in the prospect table
probably in the history the way the
table changed over time and we query
that somewhere
with a different purpose so if I'm not
careful I could end up querying the same
source table like ten different times in
different ways and it's not very clear
where I should query in order to get the
data at the level I want it for this
changes were becoming really hard to
test and debug so testing here's a
picture of airflow and the DAGs again
the way we would test this is the table
would run all at once so when we got to
700 lines with some CTS that took a
while to run because they had some
pretty complicated logic it ended up
taking a really long time to test
because we would run the table to see if
it ran it would take 45 minutes and that
it would fail look okay so something I
did broke it I would go back in make
another change run it again to see if it
passed and it would fail again and so
this this testing would end up taking
quite a lot of time even for very small
changes and it's worse if you're making
a bigger change and you don't know what
part of it broke because all of the
CTA's run in the same query debugging
even if it runs sometimes you might
introduce a join that creates duplicates
so here we have all of our prospectors
became duplicated at some point in my
query and how I would go about debugging
this when it was all one big sequel
script was I would run the first CTE I
changed the first kind of sub query see
if that created duplicates then run the
first and the second together did that
create duplicates all the way down until
I found where I introduced the duplicate
if it was a big change and as you can
imagine quite time-intensive not super
good at pinpointing things
and then there were changes in the
business logic that didn't fit cleanly
into the model we'd set up so this is a
situation where if you're getting
features for a machine learning model
and you're adding new features that
don't fit with the same ones you started
with for us what this looked like was
response or campaign attribution so I
mentioned we were using attribution to
the first response at some point talking
with the marketing team they're like you
know I think we want to incorporate the
other responses and we were like okay so
we created this table that has one row
per prospect what do we do have a
prospect has 20 responses how are we
supposed to store that in that type of
table obviously this would not work this
could you know go on forever
but people who are used to moving from
wide to long tables might notice this is
a great candidate for something like
that and that's kind of the direction we
realized we were gonna have to move is
instead of a row for each prospect and a
column for each campaign we would have a
row for each response what campaign it
was and what prospect it came from so
here you can see prospect one and two
responses to the same campaign through
70 and then I add a sequence one and two
prospect to also add two responses to
two different campaigns
so then the question was since prospect
funnel the prospect level table is not
super well-suited to the data we were
moving towards do we tear it down or do
we refactor so on the tear it down side
it was pretty clear that respect funnel
was not going to work for response based
campaign answer attribution so if we
wanted to have some amount of each
application go to each response
why are you factor so prospect funnel
was in use we didn't want there to be a
blackout period where marketing couldn't
see how well their campaigns were doing
while we decided to create something new
comparing data so we could see how well
campaign 370 did on prospect funnel and
say look it did way better on a response
based attribution maybe we should look
into why that is like is it getting a
lot of multiple responses and so on and
how how did our switch affect the way we
see our campaigns and how they performed
and then what if we decided to go back
so we were still experience
experimenting with different types of
response attribution and there was a
chance that the marketing team would be
like you know what we're getting a lot
of duplicate or spot herbs not
duplicates but like I multiple responses
to the same campaign and we don't want
to split it like that we decided we want
to go back to that first touch so then
we have a table structure and we don't
want to lose that the good news is that
response level table I showed super easy
to get from that to prospect funnel and
in fact we ended up rebasing prospect
funnel on the response table so if you
take this response table and just select
where the sequence is one you have a
prospect level table with the first
response
tada
so some things we thought about when we
were refactoring because we had 700
lines of sequel and over 30 CTS and
basically we wouldn't split that up and
make it easier to manage so here's a few
examples of CTS that we had going on I
know I have been talking about calls but
now I'm going to switch over to lead
form submissions and I promise I will go
back to calls so lead form submissions
can come through a digital source so
basically you land on a page you fill
out your information and then somebody
calls you so here I have a CTE to say
here are all my lead form submissions I
have a CT ie to pick the first one these
are based on real ones that we had in
prospect funnel I have a CTE to get that
campaign level look up so the data I
need to get the campaign from the lead
form data and then I have a link from
lead form to campaign and you start to
see the dependencies between these CTS
so here first lead form is querying all
the lead form submissions and then lead
form to campaign is querying both first
lead form and campaign level look up so
ideally I could run these first two
concurrently then run first lead form
and then run lead form two campaign
calls we have a similar pattern so we
have the call responses first call that
campaign level lookup also contains the
data to link from a marketing number to
a campaign and then we end up with all
the calls and what campaign they were
from and it starts to look kind of like
a dag right we if we call out these
dependencies explicitly it would be a
lot clearer what was happening so this
made us think we should take these cetys
break them up into tables put them on a
tag and there were some questions about
that so first the benefits so by now it
should be pretty clear what the benefits
are but I want to call them out like
the benefits of breaking into tables on
a dag the dependencies are clear this
was huge the dependencies in the SI tes
we would have to see what CTU is
querying what prior CTS vs here and this
is a ya mole template that we use but
the dag builder or the DAGs in general
do explicitly call out dependencies so
here I'm saying responses depends on
calls and lead form submissions each
table runs separately so we can see when
something fails so before when we would
run the whole thing together and a CTE
would fail we would just see that the
entire script failed here I could see
okay so campaign level lookup had no
problems and then I got to calls and
calls didn't work out and then of course
intermediate data access which is huge
so if I want to know how many calls came
from a campaign I can query the call
table that's created in that script so
each of these is instead of creating a
temporary table that only exists for a
query would create a table that exists
in the warehouse as a prep table or a
staging table or whatever words they use
for that so then the question was which
CT should get their own tables it's
because 30 tables would be a lot to
manage and not every table necessarily
needs to be called out so here we
thought about two things and one was
what intermediate data was the most
important to have access to so
definitely the response level data and
what campaign that response came from
and then whether each response resulted
in an application so all of the process
of linking and application and
downstream success metrics to a response
and then what building blocks what
tables would most easily allow for
change in the future so one of the
things that was up in the air for us was
response attribution so we definitely
wanted to have it's one table preferably
where we did the response attribution in
a way where we can change it down the
line and I'll show you what that ended
up looking like for us
but first here's a kind of an example of
what the dag ended up looking like it's
a little bit bigger than this but as we
noticed calls and lead forms both had
were treated similarly after they became
responses so we have the campaign level
lookup running first then calls and lead
form submissions running off of that
incorporating the campaign data and then
once they are combined into responses we
get the applications after that response
and then we combine it into an outcomes
table and then after that we can
reconstruct a prospect funnel and reef
and that's the refactoring part so
here's an example of response outcomes
which is how we decide to store the
campaign attribution so in this case
this is an example of an even split just
because it's easy to show here so
prospect one gave us response one in
response to and then they filed an
application and those responses were to
two different campaigns so an example of
a question I could ask from this table
so each each campaign gave us half an
application in this because we split it
evenly so I could ask how many
applications were driven by campaign to
370 and the answer here would be a half
of prospects once and all prospect twos
so one and a half so here it would be
clear that campaign to 370 outperformed
to 380
and then reiterating again we could
select one from response outcomes to get
prospect funnel basically so if we build
off of that first row in the third row
we have one line for prospect and if
applications is greater than zero I know
they applied so I can give that full one
to the to the campaign so some things we
learned and things that we think about
now and we're setting up a pipeline and
as it grows so the first question is
what are the smallest logic blocks for
this pipeline so even though we built at
a prospect level to begin with responses
ended up being a smaller logical block
and in effect we ended up
lining those together into the creation
of the prospect table without exposing
the responses themselves how do the
blocks depend on one another so this is
the dag the the the dependencies and in
fact if you are treating something
similarly like we realize calls and lead
forms or types of responses so down the
line we could just manipulate responses
that's something to call out in your
dependencies dependencies what
intermediate data might you want to
access for testing or Fran Linux
purposes so for us that was how many
responses came from a campaign how many
calls different types of responses I but
this is also relevant if you're building
features for machine learning model and
might need descriptives at some point
what kind of intermediate data might you
want to call out for for on black boxing
it or if you might need them as features
themselves down the line how will
business logic change in the future this
is the same idea as changing our
response attribution or our campaign
attribution or like adding another
feature to a pipe to a machine learning
pipeline and then how will the source
data change in the future
so for us we actually added a response
type in the past couple of months we
started collecting data on sales events
so this is when a sales agent meets up
with prospects in person and because of
the way we broke out prospect funnel we
could create a sales event table and
just treat it as any other type of
response for attribution so saved us a
lot of development time down the line
what does it look like today
um code gross so now it's a lot of
tables this is a small snapshot of it
but we still run into the issues where
we have a big chunk of code that's doing
a thing and we break it up into smaller
tables and then we also have times when
we have to take
voules that we don't really need the
intermediate data from from the middle
one and we combined them together so
it's kind of a balance that's that's
ongoing and it powers things like our
marketing top-line dashboard where we
can see things like how much we spent
over time on different campaigns and
different channels and how those
performs which is super vital to our
marketing operation when we decide where
to where to market and what channels to
market through so some future things
this is I say it's the future but our
data engineering team already built this
out and we're super excited to
incorporate it we have some data
integrity checks that we can build or we
can run in between tables and airflow so
things like are there duplicates in the
table I just ran is an entire column
null so checking those things that
wouldn't necessarily call it caused my
pipeline to fail but would eventually
cause it to fail operationally so this
is an example you can see uniqueness
validation which is things like checking
for duplicates name validations or
checking that the names are within a
certain set of values and these are
things that we would code up and put
into the dag when we specify it what to
run thank you guys so much I'm so happy
to be here I thank you to Shawn law and
Shiro's and all the organizers and
special thank you to my team at devoted
and Andrew Hoffman who worked on this
project below I put my LinkedIn and
Twitter handle so feel free to connect
with me I would love to hear from you on
times you've experienced something
related to this and questions
[Applause]
hi-yah around that what kinds of like
API guarantees or like these are public
and depend on them yes absolutely so
yeah so the question is when we build
out these intermediate tables who are
the consumers and who how do we
guarantee things like API guarantees to
those consumers so the way we do it is
we specify whether an intermediate table
is a final table or a staging prop table
if it's a staging prep table the only
people who access it are people who are
building on the pipeline if it's a final
table you can query it in our periscope
layer so you can create reports off of
it you can query it from other pipelines
so if you are working in claims and have
something that depends on marketing for
some reason you might have to do an
external task our guarantees I think are
limited to the testing framework that we
put in place
so this validity that I mentioned here
and we also are implementing a kind of
sequel testing framework on the data
engineering team I our users are limited
to analysts and data scientists at
devoted so we're not exposing this to an
external like very external where we
would need to guarantee API wise does
that answer ok great
how if at all were you able to validate
your campaign contribution
approaches was worth whoo prospects
passed anything like have you called
before
why are you that's a great question yeah
let me repeat the question and let me
know if I got this right
so what ways can we validate our
response to campaign linking and is
there some kind of feedback loop like if
we asked prospects did you call us
before we do ask prospects where they
heard about us so like a self-reported
source we don't use that as much because
it's less reliable to us than a number
that they call in on I think that's a
great idea
as far as incorporating it but not
validating via the conversations we have
with prospects right now but we could hi
yes
are you thinking about any sort of
streaming application time application
or predicting something for a prospect
didn't reveal time or you know someone
on the phone and does this sort of
approaches support right now we're
limited by the ETL copy from the
application data to our warehouse I
think real time data products are
something we've talked about I'm not
sure at the prospect level I think we
would be doing more for members first
but could this support it
I think there'd have to be a lot of
infrastructure in place to support live
data in the first place and then as far
as data pipelines running then runtime
becomes a huge thing right now runtime
is not really much of an issue except on
a debugging testing side but if we're
doing real-time it would be you know it
would have to run fast enough that the
application could consume it and show it
quickly so I think we're pretty far from
there but that would be a cool place to
be
okay let me repeat the question because
I forgot to do that in the last one so
this is how do we assess the prospect to
like campaign attribution strategies so
parabolic versus first response versus
even we have a tool to compare the way
output looks when we run different
scripts we're not running that in a
repeated way across different
attribution strategies right now but
that's something I could see us doing I
think our approach right now is closer
to what the marketing team needs and as
their needs change we would change it
but right now they haven't decided to do
a deeper investigation into the benefits
and downfalls of each type and it's kind
of hard because there's not really a
success metric on that there's just
pitfalls that you would look out for so
- I think optimizing that would be kind
of hard it would just be like a kind of
qualitative what does a run look like
from each of these and what kind of
factors do we see when we change the
attribution strategy but I think it
would be cool to do it does that answer
so I'm not a data engineer and I'm not
super qualified to talk on what we
preferred in snowflake over redshift I
can tell you snowflake is running faster
for me and I love being able to unwrap
things as somebody who has accidentally
dropped tables before snowflake
basically they store like a 24-hour
backup so you can run on drop as a
command
I've run I've ran a couple of Python
scripts that were doing that in the
background and then panicked when it
dropped a table but as far as the pros
and cons I think data engineer would be
better to talk to you about that yeah I
don't remember who was first but yeah
thanks really it takes a person a while
to call the phone number or you know
hard to make sure you know totally
repeating the question because I forgot
to do it again this is do we have some
schema for management of marketing
numbers two campaigns because it's a
really tricky problem it's totally a
tricky problem our goal eventually is to
manage that in an application layer so
the marketing team would input the
campaign and how long it's running and
so on we do there's there's all kinds of
pitfalls with the way we run marketing
number two campaign a good example is if
there's we get a call from marketing
number but there's no active campaign at
the time so it's something like somebody
got a direct mailer back in October put
it on their fridge and call us in March
which happens and then we're like okay
so we haven't used that number but can
we attribute it to that direct mail
campaign right now the way we manage it
is pretty rudimentary but I think we're
looking into better management systems
going forward we are thinking of using
there's like a dynamic one for digital
that dynamically generates a phone
number for depending on what users on
the page
we haven't implemented that yet but
that'll be a another level to this what
makes well how do you treat your members
differently than those yeah of all these
data smart do you scientists or
personnel bones you can tell what makes
you special it's a great question so I
think there are a lot of things but the
two that come to mind are the data
technology focus so we have a faster
claim turnaround than the industry
standard and which is good for provider
service we have a faster credentialing
system just because we're focused on
developing those technologies and
building things in-house where we can
from a member service perspective we
focus a lot on talking to members so we
don't have like the answering machine
that gives you the data or like the a
you can go to our online portal we don't
have a member online portal we want to
talk to people directly and we put a lot
of resources into making sure that our
phones are adequately staffed to do so
and then we emphasize and our materials
that people should call us and we give
the customer service people a lot of
power to do things for the members but
it is a complicated question
and I wish I could give you a more
thorough answer but I will say the
actual focus on members and member
experience is a cultural thing that runs
very deep at devoted their been
decisions that were made that word maybe
not great financially for the company
but better for the member and I've seen
that happen again and again and it's
it's it's a good place to be
being more available to members I will
say it so you asked about customer
service versus like making people
healthier which I think are two
different questions
we also do we have our own medical group
that supplements fee-for-service systems
so the kind of traditional health care
model where a doctor is paid for each
service that they give somebody and then
we do want to work with risk based
providers and try to provide special
payer care for that which i think is
more on the health side how we want to
make people healthier we think that risk
is important value-based care and I'm
happy to talk more offline afterwards if
one thanks everybody
[Applause]